[Musique]
il y en a toujours un qui est plus
faible à mon peu plus fort et chaque
jour c'est pas les mêmes forcément on se
soutient les uns les autres
quand on arrive on a on a un sentiment
vraiment de d'être inclus dans un groupe
et je dirais même dans une famille oui
[Musique]
en ce matin d'hiver ces jeunes mousses
embarquent à Brest sur la goélette
étoile pour deux jours de mer deux jours
ensemble
je vois personne en bas à dormir ou quoi
que ce soit vous êtes toute la journée
sur le pont l'école des monstres reçoit
en moyenne 240 élèves par an certains
viennent par vocation d'autres parce que
le système scolaire ne leur convient
plus sur ce voilier école mise en
service en 1932 les élèves apprennent à
développer leur sens marin
une instruction exigeante pour un milieu
imprévisible certains disent même que la
mer et l'espace de tous les courage
du courage ils en ont eu pour quitter
leur foyer et rejoindre cette école la
seule école militaire qui intègre des
élèves des saisons pour les préparer au
métier de marins
Hugo a parcouru des milliers de
kilomètres pour venir jusqu'ici
il a laissé derrière lui son île natal
de la Réunion pour commencer une
nouvelle vie avec de nouvelles règles
mais surtout pour découvrir une
pédagogie basée sur l'esprit d'équipage
du bateau si on va pas tous dans la même
direction pourra jamais avancer par
exemple pour XS les voiles faut qu'on
soit tous au même rythme donc faut qu'on
ait tous la même vision des choses et ça
passe ça se rapprocher le commandant du
bateau il va y personnellement pour cet
ancien sous marinier le sens du
collectif est une évidence
on le voit au fil des heures ça se
compte même pas en jour ça se compte en
heure ils mettent un pied sur le pont il
commence à attirer sur une drisse un
bout à hisser une voile et là tout de
suite il y a une émulation qui se crée
sur sur le pont on voit le travail
d'équipe qui qui se monte chacun s'est
tiré les forces et les faiblesses de
l'autre comme Hugo beaucoup sont venus
pour vivre une expérience humaine et
acquérir des compétences qui leur
permettront d'embrasser rapidement une
carrière professionnelle
au fil des années l'école de la seconde
chance est devenue celle de la réussite
personne n'est laissé de côté ni même en
bas d'une banette
et on est ennuyage ici et on doit faire
en sorte on doit surveiller que le
bateau ne sort pas de cette zone si ça
sorte de cette zone on doit rendre
compte chef de carte tout simplement
voilà et après on surveille les
alentours jusqu'à 8h
pendant que les copains se préparent
et ici la sonnerie du réveil prend une
toute autre forme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les heures passent et les gestes
deviennent plus assurés approchant une
parfaite synchronisation
au même moment à terre école des mousses
rassembler complet à vos ordres la
formation académique de la promotion se
poursuit au sein du Centre d'instruction
navale de Brest
une réponse à l'unisson pour débuter une
de ses journées qui s'annonce sans fin
ce matin pour Inès et sa section une
évaluation sur le FAMAS et son
utilisation mais avant de passer devant
l'instructeur la révision est collective
comme souvent ici gardez hors de la
détente que les organes de l'usine ne
sont pas dans l'objectif pourquoi
cette l'orientèse de 16 ans souhaite
devenir navigateur timonier pour pouvoir
embarquer déterminer la position des
navires et mettre à jour les cartes
marines le maniement des armes est pas
forcément son cours préféré mais
qu'importe aujourd'hui il faut marquer
des points donc citez-moi les cadres de
sécurité
[Musique]
l'école poussent les jeunes au
dépassement à aller au-delà de leur
limite 14 il y a des choses au revoir
leur formation durent dis-moi pendant
lesquels ils vont t'apprendre leur
métier tout en consolidant leurs acquis
scolaires
une scolarité dense à laquelle il a
fallu ajouter les contraintes liées à la
pandémie de covid 19 l'entraide devient
alors une nécessité
sur base on peut enfin on voit pas nos
parents on voit pas nos amis nos proches
donc c'est très important de compter les
uns sur les autres avec nos amis du coup
qu'on s'est fait ici tout
ça cadre élève ont su s'adapter pour que
chacun puisse atteindre ses objectifs
tout le monde a bien conscience que le
fait de poursuivre les cours en
présentiel dépend du respect du sérieux
qu'ils mettront pour l'application des
consignes ça c'est un premier point le
second point ils font peut-être un peu
plus attention à l'autre qu'il ne
l'aurait fait auparavant voilà donc je
ne dirais pas que ça facilite la tâche
mais c'est une manière d'apprendre
différemment ce qui pourrait un marin
fait partie de son ADN finalement
ok pour la section repos bonjour à tous
est-ce qu'il y a des blessés avant de
commencer
tout le monde a bien déjeuné ce matin
une journée spéciale débute sous un
crash en breton
pour le challenge des mousses les
sections de l'école vont s'affronter à
travers des activités sportives dans le
respect des règles sanitaires
et comme ses camarades Inès est bien
décidé à ne rien lâcher pour elle et
pour ses coéquipiers
[Applaudissements]
le jeu au profit du nous c'est à dire
que tout ce que je fais c'est pour le
groupe c'est pour un magasiner des
points qui vont permettre justement à la
section d'aller vers l'avant et
d'essayer d'arriver dans les premiers au
niveau du challenge
[Applaudissements]
4 3 2 1 terminé
commencez pas à venir le baisser comme
ceci vous allez vous faire mal ce genre
d'événement est important dans la
formation des mousses car il leur permet
de comprendre l'importance de la
solidarité une solidarité qui n'a ni âge
ni sexe
il y a des plus grands au début c'est un
peu difficile parce que ils se disent
que les filles sont plus faibles que les
garçons et les garçons plus forts que
les filles et s'aperçoivent que au final
ben
cette différence de sexe n'apparaît plus
dans les armées puisque on est tous on
est tous égaux face
à la mission qu'on doit remplir
[Musique]
au fil des mois privé de leur smartphone
ils se sont apprivoisés en échangeant de
vive voix coupée de leur famille ils ont
su apprendre à s'en construire une
deuxième
dans quelques mois ce qui obtiendront
leur brevet pourront signer un contrat
de quatre ans au sein de la Marine
nationale et vivre au quotidien l'esprit
d'équipage que les cadres de l'école
leur ont patiemment inculqué
[Musique]
si la cohésion se construit avec les
plus jeunes elle se vit aussi dans le
respect des anciens le poids des
traditions
c'est ce que découvre le capitaine JC
sur la base aérienne de Luxeuil en
Franche-Comté
ce jour-là cette officier de 29 ans
parents mission d'entraînement son rêve
être qualifié pilote de combat
opérationnel
en tout cas pour moi c'est une pression
qui est assez positive en fait permet de
se surpasser et puis de d'être à fond en
fait pendant tout le vol sur ces épaules
en plus de la pression imposée par sa
formation de pilote de chasse l'officier
porte aussi le poids de l'unité à
laquelle il appartient le groupe de
chasse un de cigognes
escadron pionnier son histoire est
intimement liée au plus grand nom de
l'aviation militaire française Guynemer
Fonck Garros tout son portés comme un
signe les châssis blanc et noir il
suffit d'un rapide tour dans le nid de
l'oiseau désormais installé en
Haute-Saône pour comprendre que la
mémoire de ses afes est encore bien
présente des décennies plus tard
de se passer nous conservons un héritage
matériel premier lieu des magazines
d'époque des morceaux d'avion des
reliques des pièces d'identité des
plaques d'identité mais également un
patrimoine plus immatériel qui tient
dans les valeurs que représentaient ces
pilotes donc capitaine Gilmer pour sa
combativité Roland Garros et René fond
plus pour leur inventivité et précision
tactiques et techniques pas évident
alors de trouver sa place lorsqu'on est
nouveau dans l'équipe on sent qu'on
arrive on arrive dans une unité dans un
groupe qui est déjà formé qui tourne à
priori très bien sans vous et ça sera
plutôt à vous de faire vos trous et de
vous approprier ces traditions c'est en
partie pour ça que les nouveaux
arrivants on les affecte directement à
la cellule tradition de l'unité au moins
dans leur première voire leurs deux
premières années pendant ces années
pendant lesquels ils vont pouvoir
étudier un petit peu les traditions
l'histoire de l'escadron comment il
fonctionne moi je pense que c'est
motivant parce que ça nous permet de
nous dire quand il y a un obstacle quand
il y a un petit une petite difficulté
bon il y a des gens qui sont passés
avant nous qui ont qui ont rencontré des
choses sans commune mesure avec ce que
ce que ce que nous on éprouve en terme
de difficultés et donc la moindre des
choses c'est de nous de nous investir à
100% pour pour réussir et être digne
autant qu'on peut de l'héritage qui nous
ont laissé et comme beaucoup d'autres
avant lui il veillent à ce que les
traditions perdure
c'est le cahier de marche de l'escadron
donc qui est rempli petit à petit et
dans lequel est retranscrit un petit peu
la vie au quotidien de l'escadron donc
aujourd'hui encore on a on a les anciens
cahiers de marche qui nous ont été
laissés par les par les anciens et on
peut remonter comme ça pendant pendant
plus de 50 ans
[Musique]
au fil des ans des dizaines de pages ont
été noirci du spad au Mirage 2000-5 des
tranchées de la Première Guerre mondiale
aux opérations de l'OTAN le 1 de cigogne
est toujours resté en première ligne une
histoire conservée racontée avec ses
symboles et ses rituels ce soir au bar
de l'escadron JC va vivre l'un d'entre
eux certes de manière un peu moins
festive que d'habitude covid oblige
l'escadron de chasse est un escadron
chargé d'histoire il tradition ce boulet
en est le symbole il est confié au plus
jeune arrivée à l'escadron
il représente toutes les traditions et
tu pourras le supposer tu verras
l'ampleur que cela représente ne te le
fais pas voler tu pourras le confier
qu'à tes prédécesseurs qui l'ont déjà
porté tu devras le présenter avec à la
question du jour le soir au bar de
l'escadron et lors de toutes les
cérémonies
soit en fier
représente surtout un lien qui perdure à
travers les générations parfois les
anciens qui sont du coup content de le
revoir ceux qui ont pu participer par
exemple la récupération à Cherbourg et
qu'il le retrouve lors d'une
d'un repas escadron avec les anciens de
l'escalan et qui voit le boulet qui qui
évolue en peinture parce que de temps en
temps on le rafraîchit un petit peu il
faut que les anciens nous aident parce
qu'il y a énormément de travail on a et
sans cette aide et censé être cohésion
de groupe on n'y arriverait pas tout
seul en fait on pourrait pas suivre la
formation ça serait trop difficile et
c'est cette cohésion qui nous permet de
poursuivre sereinement et de progresser
le lendemain matin les règles ont bien
été intégrées par JC et ce dès le
briefing
capitaine JC pour la question du jour
mais reste pas encore il lui faudra
encore quelques vols pour achever sa
transformation en vue de devenir pilote
de combat ensuite il pourra rejoindre
ses frères d'armes en mission avec la
certitude de toujours pouvoir compter
sur eux car c'est souvent en opération
que la fraternité d'armes s'exprime avec
force et dans certains cas elle
participe aussi à la cohésion nationale
une expérience singulière dont se
souvient le commandant Vincent Sébastien
ancien Pacha du port hélicoptère
amphibie Mistral il a vécu l'année
dernière une mission Jeanne d'Arc
inédite habituellement ces quatre à cinq
mois sont l'occasion de former les
officiers élèves de la Marine en leur
permettant de mettre en application tous
les enseignements reçus à l'École navale
accompagné de la frégate gay Prat le
mistral devait aller jusqu'en Polynésie
mais la pandémie de covid-19 a
bouleversé le programme établi
le 26 mars 2020 les deux bâtiments
prennent part à l'opération résilience
au profit de Mayotte fortement touchée
par le coronavirus nous sommes passés
par différentes phases finalement un peu
psychologique la première ça a été celle
de un peu de la sidération et d'une
certaine frustration de voir une mission
qui était planifiée pour se déployer
loin dans des pays très variés avec des
exercices et des entraînements avec les
autres marines des missions
opérationnelles des contributions à des
missions opérationnelles qui étaient
bien planifiées
de voir tout ça voler en éclat passer
cela donc il y a eu une phase évidemment
de d'adaptation à la mission ensuite et
puis aussi surtout une phase un petit
peu d'inquiétude au début puisque
parallèlement à la reconfiguration de
notre mission la France se confinait
donc les équipages étaient aussi
inquiets vis-à-vis de leur famille
rester en métropole et puis enfin je
dirais qu'il y a une phase de
mobilisation totale et d'expression de
la solidarité vis-à-vis de la population
nationale grâce à plusieurs rotations il
débarqueront à Mayotte des centaines de
tonnes de fraises humanitaires avant de
repartir dans le golfe d'Aden
dès lors l'équipage mettra tout en œuvre
pour rester à l'abri du virus
nous avons été obligés en fait de nous
isoler de nous confiner d'une certaine
manière à l'instar de ce qui s'est passé
pour la population française bien nous
nous étions confinés à bord du mistral
et de la frégate également donc nos
escales se sont cantonnés en fait à des
escales techniques de ravitaillement une
situation inédite d'autant que près de
700 personnes se trouvaient à bord du
Mistral
cette mission nous avions un hélicoptère
de la Marine mais aussi deux
hélicoptères de la version légère de
l'armée de terre un hélicoptère de la
marine italienne nous avions des troupes
amphibie qui provenaient de l'armée de
terre il faut faire la malgame il faut
acculturer tout le monde donc ça ça
prend quelques quelques jours quelques
semaines parfois mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que j'ai trouvé que au contraire
j'irai dans les difficultés
c'est là que la cohésion se fait
beaucoup plus rapidement finalement de
ce déploiement le commandant retient
surtout une expérience de commandement
hors norme on parle souvent de la
solitude du commandement je l'ai pas du
tout vécu comme ça
au contraire en fait j'ai vraiment eu le
sentiment que l'esprit d'équipage que je
prône pour lequel je dois je dois être
un aiguillon en fait il m'a aidé en
retour c'est-à-dire qu'en fin de compte
j'avais un état-major j'avais des
équipages qui finalement me soutenait
aussi d'une certaine manière dont mes
décisions et m'aider à prendre les
décisions les meilleures donc je me suis
jamais senti seul en tout cas dans dans
les décisions que j'avais à prendre
dans le Sud-Ouest Thomas le sauveteur
plongeur héliporté et Najib le
mécanicien d'équipage honteux aussi vécu
une mission particulièrement marquante
ces hommes appartiennent à l'escadron
d'hélicoptère un 67 Pyrénées une unité
des forces spéciales également experte
dans la recherche et le sauvetage le 10
novembre 2020 alors qu'ils étaient
d'alerte à Cazaux ils sont déclenchés à
8h15 pour aller secourir en pleine mer
un pêcheur souffrant d'un traumatisme
crânien
rechercher sauvetage c'est 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 donc
tous les jours il y a un pilote un
copilote un mécanisme de mécanicien
navigant qui sont d'alerte de sauveteurs
et une équipe médicale composée d'un
docteur et d'un infirmier
les deux sous-officiers embarquent à
bord d'un Caracal cette mission
consistait donc à effectuer un treillage
bateau qui est la technique la plus
compliquée de notre panel phare
rechercher sauvetage elle consiste à
demander au bateau de prendre un cap à
une vitesse allant de 5 à 10 donc assez
réduite mais suffisamment pour
stabiliser le bateau le médecin a été
descendu avec un sauveteur plongeur qui
était guidé par un plongeur qui avait
été descendu avant sur le sur le bateau
et ensuite donc on a remonté la personne
en brassière
c'est un équipement de sauvetage qu'on
utilise pour extraire les victimes la
dutrouiller sur la partie plage avant
et la plage avant était quand même
particulièrement encombrée d'objets et
d'obstacles donc la surface de où on
pouvait déposer les sauveteurs plongeurs
et le personnel médical est équivalent
d'une zone de 2 mètres sur 2 m ce qui
est assez réduit plus le bateau bouger
particulièrement avec les creux de 3
mètres
donc la phase de calme pour permettre la
dépose
du personnel et équivalente à une
trentaine de secondes par phase
en moyenne l'escadron réalise une
vingtaine de missions de ce type par an
des missions périlleuses
pages est essentielle c'est vraiment un
travail d'équipe on s'entraîne toute
l'année pour pouvoir réaliser ce type de
mission c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipe entre une bonne coordination
entre le pilote les mécaniciens
navigants les plongeurs et aussi
l'équipe médicale qui nous permet de
réaliser une mission en toute sécurité
aussi pouvoir sauver la victime c'est
grâce à cette synergie qu'on arrive à
réaliser une mission technique qui
existe un engagement important de la
personne
au sein du ministère des armées la force
du collectif est très concrète et bien
ancrée dans la réalité opérationnelle
elle est régulièrement entretenue testée
éprouvée dans des milieux difficiles
parfois hostiles
la montagne en fait partie aussi belle
que dangereuse elle et sans concession
en Savoie à Modane le gamme pour
groupement d'agrissement en montagne
accueille chaque année en stage des
unités de l'armée de terre
[Musique]
de 34 spécialistes est à la manœuvre
cette semaine il reçoivent des sapeurs
de la sécurité civile et des élèves de
l'EMIA l'école militaire interarm
chargée de former les officiers issus du
recrutement interne le but étant que
chacun y trouve son compte et que vous
repartiez d'ici encore mieux forgé que
vous ne l'êtes déjà
une adresse rapide concise qui augure
pourtant de prochaines longues journées
pour les sapeurs de Corte la première
épreuve consiste à franchir le rocher
des amoureux un premier rendez-vous avec
la verticalité où ils vont devoir faire
corps avec le massif
le but avec ce type de passage notamment
c'est de
même se découvre un petit peu en faisant
des choses inhabituelles
se découvre et se fasse confiance aussi
dans toute l'armée chez nous
c'est c'est indispensable c'est ce qui
nous permet de survivre dans nos
missions quoi voilà pas plus compliqué
que ça si on n'a pas confiance dans dans
les personnes qui sont avec nous dans
les agrès tout de suite c'est plus
compliqué voilà
les premiers exercices servent à
apprécier le niveau physique mais aussi
l'entente du groupe les difficultés vont
augmenter progressivement jusqu'à
pousser les stagiaires dans leur
retranchement pour cela les instructeurs
s'appuient sur le milieu naturel comme
sur le pic de l'aigle où ils installent
un équipement de passage
la montagne ça m'end pas c'est vraiment
une école pour ça qu'on a guéri les gens
ça fait travailler leur physique ça fait
travailler leur mental et on peut pas
mentir on peut pas tricher en montagne
alors c'est sûr quand il fait grand beau
et qu'on a des bonnes conditions c'est
plus simple mais là concrètement même
nous avec l'expérience bon on se remet
en question au fur et à mesure
mais avant de gravir ce sommet les
stagiaires de l'EMIA devront passer une
longue et fraîche nuit sous tente à 2400
mètres d'altitude une autre sorte
d'épreuve
ça va ou quoi ça va bien on est on est
dans la cohésion c'est ça tout à fait
on dort on passe plus de nuit ensemble
que qu'avec nos épouses on pète ensemble
on fait les murs ensemble on fait les
abris ensemble donc
c'est bien la montagne c'est de
l'organisation principalement si on
n'est pas organisé et que on n'est pas
un peu les uns derrière les autres sont
surveiller sont réellement s'organiser
en disant Bapt il fait froid fait un
café
il faut il faut oui ça fait partie du
jeu c'est important je pense c'est
important de continuer dans la
difficulté à pouvoir grandir
[Musique]
après avoir quitté les bras glacés de
Morphée l'heure est venue de se
confronter à un dénivelé d'une centaine
de mètres avec sac à dos armement et
équipement technique
un exercice qui nécessite un engagement
physique important et les conditions
climatiques ajoutent une pression
supplémentaire
n'est pas forcément habitué à ce milieu
donc c'est vraiment intéressant de
pouvoir
de pouvoir voir ce milieu là de près
un petit peu dans la pente voilà j'ai
entendu parfait derrière le sourire des
officiers on souffle court corps et
esprit entre en mode automatique
on tape un petit peu dans l'organisme et
dans les réserves surtout s'il y en a
qui s'alimente un petit peu mal le soir
et le matin avant les avant les
activités mais donc c'est pour ça qu'on
insiste beaucoup là-dessus sur le sur
aussi sur les consignes sanitaires quoi
mais c'est vrai que l'accumulation des
efforts pour eux l'altitude ils ont pas
non plus l'habitude d'être une altitude
aussi élevée pour eux donc forcément ça
ça travaille un petit peu toujours
pareil le mental et le physique pour
pour durer dans l'effort quoi
c'est aussi là qu'ils doivent veiller
les uns sur les autres en montagne la
moindre erreur peut être fatale
rien que dans l'esprit quand on marche
quand on fait des raquettes personne se
double on essaye de pousser la personne
devant soi pour pour la motiver et lui
donner un peu un peu plus d'énergie
l'objectif n'est pas de former des
professionnels de la montagne mais un
groupe aguerri soudé et performant
et après vous participez vous avez vos
sacs vous avez vos bâtons
au milieu vous prenez le petit cargoche
donc dans la direction de mon bras tu
vois le secteur gauche
[Musique]
ok bravo 8 personnel détruit
consommation 15%
vous mettez 12 de bout comme ça je fais
un débrief rapide
c'est difficile au niveau des secteurs
pour les destinations objectifs parce
que finalement tout se ressemblent c'est
un peu lunaire donc nous on a pas trop
l'habitude le caillou à droite le
caillou à gauche le caillou penché ça
devient vite limité c'est pour ça qu'en
fait c'est plus compliqué de tirer en
montagne parce que justement tous
ensemble ils vont retenir outre le fait
de se dépasser dans un milieu qui ne
maîtrise pas avec des franchissements
comme vous avez pu suivre déjà ce matin
et là travailler aussi l'aspect
commandement qui est important pour eux
tant que cofficier de l'armée de terre
commander au feu c'est aussi savoir
remporter l'adhésion de ces subordonnés
apprécié leur valeur en situation de
fatigue ou de stress
eux ils vont descendre donc en tactique
voilà donc moi le but c'est ça va être
de les prendre la partie donc voir déjà
comment ils vont réagir voilà et en
fonction de ça bah là on va pas on va
pas rester en défensif donc là c'est
juste vraiment pour les pour les fixer
et après nous on va se replier
ils ont pris ils ont manœuvré ils sont
finalement ils sont rentrés dans le
talbug complètement à gauche c'est
l'arroser là
après c'est à nous de nous adapter
[Applaudissements]
quand la cohésion est là tout semble un
peu plus facile la construire est donc
essentiel pour les militaires qu'il
parle d'esprit de corps d'équipage ou
d'équipe d'entraide de fraternité
d'armes ou même d'amitié
[Musique]